well the stunner of the day comes from
the New York Jets this is something that
had been percolating Chris Sims we had
talked about it previously it had been
poo pooed by the likes of Jets head
coach Adam GaSe but now general manager
Mike mechag ninh is out that's his
reward for participating in the hiring
of gays for presiding over a free agency
period that saw the likes of Le'Veon
Bell joined the team and presiding over
a draft that resulted in the landing of
Quinton Williams at number three overall
but this had been coming whatever the
reasons and ultimately the reasons our
best interest to the team Christopher
Johnson the chairman and CEO decided to
make the move I'm not surprised because
we knew it was coming I'm surprised it
took this long after the draft yeah I
think to me too I mean yes I know you
put it on my radar there was a bunch of
other people that I had talked to around
the NFL that thought this was a very
real possibility that it could happen
you know right immediately after the
draft all of that I don't know what the
reason is for waiting maybe they just
didn't like the overall optic optics of
it whatever may be but yeah obviously
there was some sort of gist discontent
or happy unhappiness about what mechag
ninh was doing with the New York Jets
within the organization and I and hey
you and I both know there was definitely
frustration from the Jets fans about
mechag Ninh and his building of the team
over the last few years yeah and and i
think that that frustration came to a
head with the the decision to pay levy
on bail what they paid him it's not that
they signed him it's that they paid him
what they paid him and you know as that
was all going down and there was phony
interest it was being put out there on
the part of the Baltimore Ravens the
Jets really did overpay Le'Veon Bell and
you pay him to the point where you have
to make him your workhorse now you can't
make him part of a 2 or 3 man rotation
kind of ties the head coach his hands
forces him to justify the acquisition
and I suspect Gates was pushing back
against the offers that were being made
maybe wanting instead to go with a guy
like a Tevin Coleman who would have been
a lot cheaper but gates lost that battle
ultimately may have helped him win the
war and it could be bell staying away
from offseason workouts is the thing
that pushed it in cases favored because
it gave
gave gates the opportunity to say see
guys I told you so yeah well I you know
I I don't doubt anything you said there
certainly I mean you make some good
points I think there's a few moments
that I look at over the year that have
kind of over the years I should say that
have kind of set this up for you make
the levy on bail point I think that's
spot-on I mean from everything we know
and I know and the teams that I know
that we're involved in the be there was
no market for Le'Veon Bell there was
none the market was literally levy on
Bell's agent calling around the team's
going hey you can sign levy on bail for
this this price because nobody was
bidding high numbers or what they wanted
and then teams got involved in like whoa
we can get him for eight million dollars
a year whoa whoa okay well let's think
about this we'll call you back we'll let
you know
ultimately the Jets paid more money than
anybody else I think was willing to
offer so that's not a good look for the
GM right then
Anthony Barr skips town that kind of
doesn't look good on the GM looks like
they overpaid Tremaine Johnson and free
agency from two years ago he didn't get
off to a very good start there was talk
about being a trade for Coolio Mack that
never came to fruition so I look at
those moves that all had to the piling
on of a mic mckagan that really began
with drafting horrible picks like
Christian Hackenberg in the second round
when he had no business being drafted in
the first five round six rounds maybe I
feel like that's where it began also
with Bryce petty not being able to find
that quarterback seems to be a theme
Mike in New York that the Jets fans felt
like he only made good picks when guys
just fell to him like Leonard Williams
or Jamal Adams or even this year Quinn
and Williams at three I don't think
everybody was a fan of some of his team
building from there on now there's
another angle to this that I think is
very important and it is how long was
this building was this something
Christopher Johnson thought about doing
after the 2018 season but decided only
to fire coach Todd Bowles for now or was
he intent on keeping McKagan until Adam
GaSe gets into building and maybe starts
pointing some things out you know the
power struggle that often arises when a
new coach wins games and has success and
flexes his muscle gaze flexing muscle
before he even has any muscle
right he hasn't done anything with the
Jets yet and he was able to build a case
if that's how it went down to result in
Christopher Johnson making the change
and look if it's the former if this was
something that he planned to do all
along my reaction is you just should
have done it then just get rid of
everybody and start from scratch get a
new GM get a new head coach if it's the
latter it shows that gas is able to make
a pretty compelling case behind closed
doors for Christopher Johnson to do what
gace wanted him to do which is tell
McKagan to get on down the road and now
gase is the interim GM they're gonna
hire a new GM but here's the question
will the new GM have the power mechag
ninh had or will the new GM be setting
the table for Adam GaSe yeah well I
would add amis of course had full
authority over the Miami Dolphins roster
that did not exactly go perfect now so I
would hope and at least my perfect world
because I'm an Adam GaSe fan that they
bring in the GM of course that he has
some sort of a relationship with or a
working relationship or someone that he
respects so they can get on the same
page and then work cohesively together
to build the correct football team you
know I don't know where it all went
dysfunctional with Mike McKagan to make
your to answer your question that is
really interesting I do think like Adam
GaSe or maybe somebody in the Jets
organization have been talking to
ownership and pointed out some flaws
within the roster and things that mike
McKagan had done over the years so I
certainly think there's there was issues
there altogether but you know I think
the big reason why we didn't see a
change immediately or whatever it is is
just because hey the Jets out of a lot
of money had a lot of money to spend in
free agency I think they knew it was a
big year so then they let mechag Ninh
I guess stay on because they felt like
gosh a lot of the heavy lifting was done
at this point and they had a game plan
for what they wanted to do for you
agencies and then you get to deep into
the draft process where teams don't want
to start over with the new staff in the
front office and scouting and everything
like that and feel like they're behind
or not prepared in the draft process to
where they just let the offseason play
out and now they're gonna move forward
with a clean slate it'll be interesting
to know how much juice mechag Ninh
actually had in free agency and in the
preparation for the draft because I
remember when Charlie Cassell a who got
McKagan and the job was
essentially let go by the Texans they
let him hang around after the season
ended he didn't have a lot of juice or
really any juice in the draft that
resulted in Mario Williams being number
one overall but the owner didn't want to
look foolish for firing both Dom Capers
and Charlie Castley at the same time I
mean maybe Christopher Johnson was just
thinking let's have some lag here let
this guy keep around and hold it
together but I'll make the decisions or
the new coach will help me make the big
decisions and Mike mckagan is just kind
of here as an administrator more than
anything else
I mean maybe that'll come out at some
point I don't know but this was coming
and it is a surprise because here we are
three weeks after the draft almost I
think they put the brakes on it because
word got out I did write I think he
would have been fired right after the
draft yes but it's almost like they
didn't want legitimized the reports by
firing him right away because I see the
time Chris Christopher Johnson had
needed to come out and say this is false
if it's false and he didn't which I
think tells us in hindsight everything
we needed to know yeah no I think you're
you're spot-on there that's the same
feeling I got to it's just like they
didn't want to bow to the fact that the
media had exposed something that was out
there you know the big thing going
forward is who's it gonna be you know as
far as names that are out there one name
that I've heard connected to the
situation is a guy from Philadelphia Joe
Douglas that would be one name that I've
heard that's from a few different people
that might be high on the radar for the
New York Jets we'll see where it goes
but Mike too one overarching issue and I
think this is an NFL thing that bothers
me right now is the and you know you
talk about mckagan and how he ended up
with the Jets hey everything I know I
mean this a hundred percent and I've
talked to a lot of people about this
Mike McKagan was going to be fired by
the Houston Texans he was on his way out
the door they were gonna fire him but in
the new thing in the NFL its ownership
likes to call up old has-been GM's who
were not connected to the game anymore
and have lost touch and they go help us
find a guy for right now and and we make
the proper hiring and in this case the
Jets asked Charlie Casserly Charlie
Cassidy's friend was Mike mckagan and he
gets hired a lot like Ernie Accorsi with
the Giants hiring his old friend get
home you know Dave gentlemen so that to
me is going on too much in the NFL right
now and it speaks to the overarching
problem in the NF
it's very it's become very political the
league more political now than ever and
it's not about what you know it's about
who you know that's become more
important than actually being good at
your job and that's wrong and that's why
I think we see more idiots around the
league than ever before and and Chris
Sims said all those things yes I did
Chris have said Chris Sims Chris Sims
called Charlie Kelly a washed-up
has-been GM but here's the thing and and
this is human nature and the owners need
to understand this when you hire a
consultant to do the thing that you're
not equipped to do on your own you are
inviting that person to hire a friend or
a family member or a family member of a
friend exactly the person who makes the
recommendation then has the ear of the
person who gets the job and if it's a
friend who is going to feel indebted to
you that person's gonna take your calls
that person's gonna listen to what you
have to say so you're still in the game
even when you're not in the game and
maybe it's Charlie Castle either told
Mike mechag men to draft Christian
Hackenberg we'll never know the answer
to that one but we do know that it's an
important reality for owners to keep in
mind you hire that consultant you
entrust that job to that consultant the
consultants gonna hire somebody who's
gonna listen to that consultant and let
that consultant feel relevant right
maybe years after the point where anyone
should have been listening to that
consultant is anyone else we can piss
off before we wrap this up I think we
did it all we've almost said all 32
teams so good job any anything else you
want to add no I think I think that's it
you know I think we really hit it all I
don't really look at any other thing
that we haven't said I got a few notes
written down here I feel like we hit
them all so good job by you man all
right hey thanks for hurrying up and
getting to the studio quickly so it
didn't have to wait here 10 minutes for
you I appreciate you you mean you had a
wait at home in your luxury house I mean
oh my gosh sorry some of us are here at
the office let me explain to you how
this works when something like this
happens I end up writing ten different
stories about it waiting for you to get
to the studio keeps me from doing that
I'm not sitting outside getting a suntan
obviously so I've got to get back to
work so you get to work I'll get to work
and then if somebody else gets fired
today we'll come back and do this as
long as the person who gets my
if anybody gets fired I've had enough of
you I'm waiting till tomorrow morning
I'm out of here the hell with you later
see everybody won't walk more about this
tomorrow morning on pft live everybody
have a great Wednesday see you man
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports